a lo largo y ancho del viejo continente
miles de personas han protagonizado
diversas jornadas de protesta en reclamo
de calidad de vida la subida de los
precios de los alimentos del combustible
y de demás servicios afecta los
bolsillos y aumenta la indignación entre
los gremios a los que debemos la
estabilidad en crisis como la pandemia
de Kobe 19 para el análisis de este
fenómeno nos acompaña Pedro García
Bilbao él es sociólogo y profesor de
estructura social contemporánea en la
universidad de rey Juan Carlos también
es analista de la sociedad europea
Muchas gracias a usted Pedro por estar
con nosotros
pues encantado de poder compartir este
tiempo de análisis con ustedes en France
Pues entremos en materia muchas de las
grandes protestas incluyen a los gremios
del transporte y de la salud hemos visto
ciudades paralizadas por las huelgas
Como por ejemplo en Francia que además
mañana tiene otra protesta contra la
reforma de las pensiones de Manuel
macron Por qué no es viable el aumento
de la edad de jubilación y si no es así
cómo se soluciona el déficit del sistema
que además no solamente es en Francia
bien el aumento
es viable Es que es algo rechazado en
Francia Por una parte importante de la
población que considera
un retraso En la jubilación supone una
pérdida laborales idos no
el tema de salud y en Europa es casi
universal como en Estados Unidos
hay tensión en la edad de
Pedro le voy a tener que pedir el favor
que se acerque un poco más a su
micrófono porque por momentos lo pierdo
entonces Disculpe y continúe con su idea
bien lo que estaba diciendo es que hay
un debate en Europa sobre si es posible
mantener el sistema de jubilaciones en
los franjas de edad que existe ahora en
cada uno de los países y La respuesta es
claramente política técnicamente es
posible el sistema permite perfectamente
que haya jubilaciones en los márgenes de
edad que son normales y vigentes ahora
en cada país pero existe una tensión con
los derechos con los derechos de las
personas respecto de las presiones de
los sectores bancarios y los sectores
neoliberales que desean la sustitución
de los sistemas públicos por las
pensiones privadas Y eso implica también
retrasar Las edades de jubilación pero
en última instancia es un problema
político y lo que vemos con las en
España en Francia fundamentalmente pero
es una constante en toda Europa no con
las movilizaciones en este tema como en
otros es que una parte importante de la
población europea no desea retrocesos en
lo que se ha dado en Llamar el estado
del bienestar Ahora hay un esta crisis
tiene que ver mucho con la falta de
fuerza laboral que es a su vez otra
crisis también en varios países europeos
y que está pasando por ejemplo muy
claramente en Reino Unido maestros y
trabajadores de la salud prefieren
renunciar y en muchos casos migrar a
otros países ante lo que consideran un
salario que no les Permite llevar una
vida digna y que no crece a la par de la
inflación en Reino Unido es un caso
especial Además porque es la única gran
Economía del mundo que no ha podido
recuperar sus niveles pre pandemia y en
esta situación pues entonces cuál es la
salida aparte de salir a protestar
bueno Inglaterra como usted muy bien
Dice es un caso muy particular
Inglaterra se ha visto enormemente Gran
Bretaña se ha visto enormemente afectada
ha tenido unas consecuencias sociales
negativas muy fuertes el brexit es decir
la salida de la Unión Europea ha
supuesto un verdadero terremoto en los
equilibrios internos laborales y
sociales de Inglaterra están pagando muy
duramente una decisión precipitada que
se llevó a cabo y que a todas luces ha
tenido consecuencias muy negativas es
decir en Inglaterra hay realmente se ha
estado produciendo en los últimos meses
una escalada de huelgas en distintos
sectores la sanidad el transporte
en muchísimos frentes y por qué está
teniendo lugares esto por el aumento del
nivel el aumento del gasto de vida es
decir el coste de la vida se ha
disparado enormemente esto
está en relación pues con la falta de
precios adecuados en
en El combustible con el coste de las
importaciones hay que pensar que todo se
ha visto todo completamente alterado por
la salida de la Unión Europea y Quién ha
pagado ese precio fundamentalmente las
clases populares
británicas no Y entonces en este sentido
el gobierno conservador ya hemos visto
quiso hacer cambios en los impuestos ha
tenido Se ha producido un cambio en el
liderazgo británico pero la
conflictividad laboral y social sigue
aumentando en este sentido es el hombre
enfermo de Europa en este momento es
Inglaterra no o el Gran Bretaña perdón y
sí tiene que ver evidentemente con el
brexit también con las con la situación
que se ha abierto en el este de Europa
con la guerra en Ucrania pero sobre eso
quería preguntarle también porque miles
de personas también se han tomado las
calles en varios países justamente
contra las políticas de la Unión Europea
y su respuesta a la Guerra de Ucrania
los líderes europeos no solamente tienen
que lidiar con el desafío de suministrar
a Ucrania para que se pueda defender de
Rusia sino que ahora también tienen la
tarea de calmar a sus ciudadanos
molestos porque los fondos que necesitan
ellos se están yendo para Ucrania
Sí desde luego vamos a ver hay la
conflictividad general que observamos en
Europa tiene tiene que ver con el clima
general de retroceso de ataques al
Estado del bienestar es decir a las
coberturas sociales con especificidades
propias de cada país que tienen
situaciones ligeramente distintas no
entonces el clima general que hay ahora
es el el que se ha generado desde hace
un año con la situación de guerra en
Ucrania y el cambio de alianzas es decir
se ha esfumado completamente la
expectativa de llegar a un entendimiento
con Rusia en una colaboración económica
de venta de energía por parte de Rusia
hacia Europa y e inversiones y
exportaciones europeas a Rusia eso ha
desaparecido el coste de la energía ha
experimentado Un aumento brutal en toda
en toda Europa
y
se ha producido un de la relación de
dependencia de Estados Unidos que por
otra parte no puede tampoco satisfacer
plenamente las necesidades energéticas
de Europa y claro cuando la energía
entra en escena todos los demás sectores
se ven afectados aumenta la inflación
aumenta el coste de la producción
agrícola aumenta el coste de la
movilidad de las personas es decir todos
los sectores se ven afectados entonces
hay movilizaciones específicas en contra
de la guerra en Europa bien no podemos
decir que haya habido movilizaciones
comparables a las que hubo en el pasado
cuando fue la por ejemplo la agresión a
Irak Bueno pues estas estas
movilizaciones no se han producido ha
habido movilizaciones puntuales actos de
protesta etcétera en contra de la
situación de guerra o por ejemplo cuando
fue la Cumbre de la otan en Madrid pues
hubo una gran movilización puntual de
aquel día lo que sí hay son
movilizaciones sociales están
literalmente relacionadas con las
consecuencias de la opción bélica que se
ha tomado y la y la y la forma concreta
en la que Alemania España Francia y los
países de la otan han decidido apoyar a
Ucrania esa forma concreta implica
traslado e inversiones
hacia hacia el sector bélico hacia la
parte bélica inversiones En armamento
pero también sobre todo lo que implica
es aceptar que el principal proveedor de
energía va a ser Estados Unidos a unos
precios completamente distintos a los
que había por ejemplo pues hace un año y
claro eso va a tener consecuencias
sociales evidente